THE FIRST MINUTE OF GAME ONE.
UNDER WAY, GAME
GETTING A TRUE BOUNCE OFF THE
BOARDS.
>> Chris: KNOCKED AWAY FROM PE.
HERE'S MIKAEL BACKLU THE BOARDS.
BLAKE COLEMAN WILL FIRE IT
AROUND TO THE NEARSIDE FORALL T.
TH WHO TAKES
MOST OF THE DRAWS ON THIS LINE
DARNELL NURSE.
THAT'S HOW YOU DRAW IT UP
AND A QUICK COUNTER HERE AS
HYMAN STARTS AWAY.
OUT T A 3-ON-1.
ZACH
BARRIE.
NUGENT-HOPKINS.
CAN'T GET THE WE  ON A POWER
PLAY MARKER.
THREE STRAIGHT FORND THE NET.
WATCH THE SHOOT AROUND BY
KYLINGTON TO JOHNNY GAUDREAU. S
SEVEN GOAL
REGULAR SEASON GAMES WITHOUT A
GOAL.
AND THE FIRSTTAYS ONSIDE
IT BACK TO DRAISAITL.'T CENTRE .
MIKAEL BACKATES OF THE
DEFENDER.
AND THERE'S COLEMAN DRIVING HAR.
WE'RE PRETTY SURES A KICKING
ACKLUND
RIGHT BACK IN.
GAME FIVE AND McDAVID